today it's going to be kenta maeda
making his eight starts maeda will try
to atone for the worst start of his
twins career
it came in oakland it was the final game
of that series he only lasted three
innings and gave up seven earned runs
gave up a couple of home runs so he's
hoping for better results here today
that one lofted towards center field and
that's going to bounce in front of
kepler for a base hit so canada opens up
the ball game with a single seth brown
checks in batting at 219 with five home
runs and out in front again he gets a
strikeout very nice split figure change
up right there maybe the perfect spot
and now ramon lauriano and the 1-1 a
ground ball up middle polanco there
glove steps on second throws to first
double play and that ends the a's first
inning chris bassett making his ninth
start of the season and he's becoming a
bricklayer and what i mean by that is
each and every time out he's got a game
plan he is laying the foundation and
continues to build off of that
slaps it
toward left canna over into foul
territory near the seats and he caught
it up against the netting canna braced
himself just a little bit reached into
the netting and grabbed it he's gonna
put his hand up brace it
look at that's around the netting kite
wow that's a terrific even better than
we thought so here's donaldson
flashing the leather
chapman scoops chap and throws in time
to get donaldson fish to jorge polanco
is swung on a ground ball to first
backhand olson goes to the bag and
that's a one two three bottom of the
first for bassett matt olson leads off
top of the second
and this one is spoke to right center
field that's going to get down for a hit
hitler backhands it on the warning track
olson's going to dig for second and he's
going to have a stand-up double it's a
lead off double to begin the a second
nobody out can bring up matt chapman
is bounced into right field of acid here
comes matt olsen here comes the throw to
the plate it'll be cut off by ceno
they'll throw the second and chapman is
out well i think what they're gonna take
a look at is whether or not the actual
tag was applied but take a look here
this is where chappie he sees the throw
as far as i'm seeing kype i'm not seeing
the tag applied so he is well they call
him out bob can't believe it quite
frankly i don't understand that one
either oakland won twins nothing top two
bases empty two outs and now chad pinder
once again the 3-2 pitch strike three
called on a breaking ball and finder
strikes out looking raising his arm so
mayday struck out two through two the
a's get one now nelson cruz will lead
off the bottom of the second and that's
swung out of miss and a fastball outside
chased by cruz one away lardek is coming
up one out bassett to larnick and deals
two two a swinging a line drive into
right drifting near the corner that's
going to land for base hit shy of brown
the twins have their first hit first
base runner one out knock from learning
going to bring up miguel cino the yo one
inside near the hands and i think that
hit him or is it a foul ball as lipka
raises his arms and now they're going to
say if cenote did swing at it i don't
think he did
on appeal and now miguel is going to be
given first base danny i believe here it
hit the knob of his bat went to first
base they turned they completed the
double play remember they lost their
lost their challenge yes they can't you
know hit by pitch is one that you can
look at but you need to challenge it and
it had to have hit part of the bat for
it to go where it went two on one out
here's max twins down one nothing bottom
two get something going here he's
probably gonna see some fastballs kepler
gives it a ride to right center field
twins three a's one number four for max
one swing of the bat twins lead by a
pair
that's the fifth home run allowed by
bassett all five to left-handed batters
and that was a kepler rocket luisa rise
is the batter two on one out and he
slaps this one toward left center field
loriano goes into a slide makes the
catch on the exchange the ball pops out
of his glove he hustles after it throws
it back in quickly deloreano caught it
and then as he was coming up to make a
throw
that's when the ball rolled away from
him the twins in front three to one
shawn murphy will lead off the third
inning for oakland
spears the line drive nearly won a gold
glove last year a line drive looked to
be ticketed for center field kenta with
the red glove
left arm extended right above his head
home half of the third here come the
twins second and third nobody out now
the a's bringing the infield in with
larnick at the plate
strike three called on the big overhand
curve so that's a huge out and that
loads him up for kepler lockwood third
cruise at second cenos at first a high
fly left center field
lorianno over now and there's the catch
polanco coming home here comes the throw
in time to get him what a throw by
l'oreal
oh i don't know
i don't know either i i think it's
another play where did he ever get the
glove to him oh i think he i think his
foot was in there well in advance
headsets are off and polanco is going to
be
safe
and if bob melvin stays in this game
i'll be surprised almaida will pitch to
l'oreal leading off the oakland fourth
inning
donaldson scoops
good play with ceno stretching on the
other end one down orianna runs well but
a nice play and miguel sano stretched
way out there two out base hit that'll
get jed lowry to the plate pitch at the
left field
rise back
on the warning track he'll have room
and puts it away he is have a start in
the fifth inning so chad pinder had a
double yesterday to right center and
he's got a double to right center today
here is sean murphy
this one is driven
left center field and that'll get down
for a hit and rise cuts it off
pinder's gonna score murphy will stay at
first and it's a four to two game and
the bases are loaded nobody out four
straight hits off maeda and that's going
to be it for the right-hander maida
duffy comes in out of the bullpen to
face seth brown a left-handed hitter
taps it slowly polanco's gonna get the
only out he can and that's at first base
run comes in to score that's murphy out
number one but now the a's are down by
just one run so here's lauriano who's
out for two
grounded
to simmons simmons has it and now andrus
is going to be in a rundown it'll be
andrus
is knocked over and they're gonna call
interference on the catcher and the runs
gonna score
rortfett ran into albus andrus and when
that happens in a rundown it's
interference a huge break for the a's
elvis andrews running straight
savvy so now a four pitch walk will fill
them up loads them back up and here's
chapman
chapman hits a high pop-up
coming in blarnak
ken is at third cannas gonna try to
score the throw to the plate is cut off
the throw to third is late and the run
comes in to score in the a's lead not
real deep but chapman gets the job done
with a sac fly to right and he is lead
5-4 in an eventful top of the fifth
inning then we go to the seventh
somebody a's load the bases and here
comes chapman with a chance to bust it
open for
oakland check swing slowly hit up the
third base line and it's gonna be a hit
and it's gonna be a run and the a's lead
six to four
a little excuse me swing roller up the
third base line base is still loaded
still one out here's lowry
donaldson will go to the bag
fire across double play
nice play by donaldson and out of all
that the a's got just one they lead by
two the a's score one but the twins are
still very much in this game bottom of
the eighth ace lead by two kepler at the
third there's andrew ten simmons he's by
two first pitch a swinging a drive left
field and deep beckett goes deep it goes
at the wall
simmons ties the game
the twins get to defend again
in the eighth inning of target field
this one ties the game six six of a
second from
[Applause]
by the shortstop ninth finney coming up
as laureato gives these a shot as the
go-ahead run is on base with one out in
the ninth so here's olson who's two for
three the delivery to matt is a check
swing comebacker rogers turns goes to
second and throws it away the ball winds
up in center field mariano gets up and
he goes to third and these runners at
first and third
could have been an inning ending double
play instead the a's have first and
third and one out donaldson just missed
it donaldson looking at his glove
immediately first and third and
chapman's coming up in a six six game in
the ninth man check swing did he go but
the ball gets away rolls back to the
screen and the ace take the lead
lauriano has scored i was hoping for
that so chapman strikes out they checked
with the first base unpartitioner he
said he went around but the golf ball
goes to the backstop lorianno scores and
the a's lead 7-6 we go to the bottom of
the ninth wins keep the door ajar in the
ninth time run is on and now ceno will
have one more shot to carry his team
hit to right biscotti coming in piscotty
gets there and that's the ball game
and he is retired and so are the twins
and the a's hang on and win a wild one
this afternoon in minnesota to take the
series